i think there are big changes coming
around you've even seen this language
from the left
in recent in recent days they've talked
about the green new deal
right then evoking the new deal is
evoking franklin delano roosevelt
the new deal was a major some say
irreversible structural change to our
constitutional order
you've heard about court packing that's
actually another idea that came from fdr
you've heard about lots of other major
changes well
the lincoln project the lincoln project
is out with a
very scary commercial well you know the
lincoln project are a bunch of these
con artists unemployed ex-republican
operatives
and campaign consultants so they're
they're raising a lot of money from
left-wingers and they've aired this
commercial
with a big fear that if president trump
gets reelected
he might never give up power
ohio florida they all just started
falling in line
hey honey
[Applause]
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
who won
trump trump won
but i thought you could only be
president two times
[Applause]
not anymore
[Applause]
the lincoln project is responsible for
the content
of course the lincoln project is
responsible now there is a real irony
here
which is these left wingers and i
include the lincoln project
among them we're talking about how we
need
a new deal like fdr gave us how we need
to pack the courts like fdr tried to do
and we need to be very afraid of trump
running for a third term
like wait for it fdr did
also ran for a fourth term actually the
only way we got rid of that american
monarch was because he died in office
finally
and then they passed a constitutional
amendment to stop people from doing that
every president before fdr had followed
george washington's example
and not served more than two terms
except for fdr the american monarch the
one that the left wants to go back to
this is what the left does they always
always project
i mean i got to tell you that commercial
got me really excited for trump's third
term i just
i don't think he's willing to do it i
want him to go in like charles ii
and say congress you are dissolved go
home
i am the emperor it's not going to
happen not going to happen sorry guys
sorry lincoln project
now the lincoln project none of them
actually believe that's going to happen
the lincoln project is the most
dishonest hack movement in politics that
i've seen
in my lifetime okay it is just
pure grift i know that word gets abused
a lot these days grift and grifter
it means con artist and it's basically
used
to to apply to anyone that you disagree
with that's how it's become popular
but there is a specific use of this and
the specific use applies to the lincoln
project they are
con artists they don't believe anything
the reason they started the lincoln
project is because they were
out of work gop campaign consultants
who couldn't get hired anymore because
it was trump's party now and he kicked
all of them out
so they gave up all of their principles
and became democrats
if they had any principles in the first
place and they
a lot of them were in debt some of them
were in were lobbyists for russia i mean
these
these
are corrupt dudes who've been working in
politics
for a very long time so they just air a
bunch of nonsense but the way it works
actually my kind of defense of the
lincoln project
and why i think some conservatives
should come around to it is all the
lincoln project is doing
is lining the pockets of these
unemployable campaign consultants
by milking democrats so it is
it the lincoln project is a wealth dis
redistribution scheme
to take idiot gullible democrats money
and give it to
unemployed gop campaign consultants
give you another example they just put a
couple billboards up in times square
jared kushner saying new yorkers are
going to suffer and that's their problem
and this is a quote obviously taken way
out of context from from jared kushner
and then it's next to one of ivanka who
i don't know why ivanka's on the
on the billboard but it says 33 000 new
yorkers dead
224 000 dead americans
like that's ivanka's fault like ivanka
killed them also
what if the if the number of new yorkers
dead is so disproportionate to the
number of americans
maybe that's not the trump's fault maybe
that's the fault of
andrew cuomo the governor of new york or
bill de blasio the mayor of new york
right i don't know why that would become
the republican spot but it actually
doesn't matter
why are there billboards up in new york
why is a
a campaign organization that is
dedicated to
kicking trump out of office why are they
spending their money a lot of money
on billboards in new york trump's not
going to win new york
it's not a battleground state that's a
that's a democrat state
the reason they're doing that is so that
they can advertise for the lincoln
project
and get more money they've been doing
this on morning joe nobody watches
morning joe except for
gullible leftists who are likely to give
money
to leftist organizations so they've been
running advertisements on morning joe
in washington dc people aren't going to
vote
for donald they're going to washington
dc is taxation without representation to
begin with
but they're not going to vote for trump
you know even even if they were gonna
play a significant role in the
presidential election
they're not gonna vote for trump there
it's just a way of taking money from
democrats and that's totally fine by me
it's kind of funny
i almost respect these con artists a
little bit more
than the crazy people because there are
these these hacks like the lincoln
project
and then there are people who genuinely
believe this stuff that they're putting
out there
there's one video in particular a woman
crying in her bathtub over trump that is
not even over trump over amy coney
barrett that is uh
really a work of performance art i hope
you enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you